what i want to do in this video is think
about how the normal force might be
different in different scenarios and
since my two and a half year old son is
obsessed with elevators i thought i
would i would focus on those
so here i've drawn four scenarios and we
could imagine them almost happening in
some type of a sequence so in this first
in this first picture right over here
i'm going to assume that the velocity is
equal to zero or another way to think
about it is this elevator is stationary
and everything we're going to be talking
about in this video i'm talking about in
the vertical direction that's the only
dimension we're going to be dealing with
so this is zero meters per second zero
meters per second per second in the
vertical direction another way to think
about it this thing is not moving now
also it is also and this may be is
somewhat obvious to you but its
acceleration is also zero meters per
second squared in this picture right
over here
then let's say that i'm sitting in this
transparent elevator and i press the
button and so the excel the the elevator
begins to accelerate upwards so in this
video right over here or this screen
right over here let's say that the
acceleration
the acceleration is two
meters per second and i'll use the
convention that positive means upwards
or negative means downwards we're only
going to be operating in in this one
dimension right here i could write 2
meters per second times times the j unit
vector because that tells us that we are
now moving let me just leave it like
that that tells us that we're moving in
the upward in the upward direction
and let's say we do that for
one second and then we get to this
screen right over here so we were we had
no velocity we move we accelerate let me
oh this is 2 meters per second squared
let me make sure
it's 2 meters per second per second this
is acceleration here so we do that for 1
second and then at the end of one second
we stop accelerating so here and this
once we get to this little screen over
here our acceleration goes back to zero
meters per second squared in the j
direction although you don't have to
write that because it's really just zero
but now we have some now we have some
velocity we did that for just for the
sake of simplicity let's say we this
screen lasted for one second so now our
velocity is going to be two
meters per second in the j direction
in the j direction or in the upwards
direction
and then let's say we do that for 10
seconds so we travel at least at the
constant velocity we travel for 20
meters we travel a little bit while
we're accelerating too but we're getting
close to our floor and so the elevator
needs to decelerate the elevator needs
to decelerate so it decelerates
so then it decelerates the acceleration
here is negative two meters per second
squared
times
times in the j direction so it's
actually accelerating downwards now has
to slow it down to get it back to
stationary so what i want to do is think
about what would be the normal force the
force that the floor of the elevator is
exerting on me in each of these
situations and we're going to assume
that we are operating near the surface
of the earth
so in every one of these situations if
we're operating near the surface of the
earth the i have some type of
gravitational attraction to the earth
and the earth has some type of
gravitational attraction to me
and so let's say that i'm i don't know
let's just make the math the math simple
let's say that i'm some type of a
toddler and i'm 10 kilograms
10 kilograms
so maybe this is my son although he's i
think he's 12 kilograms but we'll keep
it simple
so this is it's 10 this person has a oh
let me be clear he doesn't weigh 10
kilograms that's wrong he has a mass of
10 kilograms weight is the force due to
gravity mass is the amount of stuff the
amount of matter there is although i
have that's not a rigorous definition so
the mass of the individual of this
toddler sitting in the elevator is 10
kilograms so what is the force of
gravity or another way to think about it
what is this person's weight
well
in this in this vignette right over here
and this picture right over here it's
mass times the gravitational field near
the surface of the earth 9.8 meters per
second squared let me write that over
here the gravitational field near
near the surface of the earth is 9.8
meters per second squared and the
negative tells you it is going downward
so you you multiply this times 10
kilograms
the force
the downward force the force of gravity
the force of gravity is going to be 10
times negative 9.8 meters per second
squared so negative
newtons and i could say that that's
going to be in the j
in the j direction
well what's going to be the downward
force of gravity here well it's going to
be the same thing we're still near the
surface of the earth we're going to
assume that the gravitational field is
roughly constant although we know it
slightly changes with the distance from
the center of the earth but when we're
dealing on the surface we assume that
it's roughly constant
and so we'll assume
we have the exact same force of gravity
there and of course
this person's mass this toddler's mass
does not change
depending on going up a few floors
so it's going to have the same force of
gravity downwards in every one of these
situations
in this first situation right here the
person is this person has no
acceleration if they have no
acceleration in any direction and we're
only concerning ourselves with the
vertical direction right here that means
that there must be no net force on them
this is from newton's first law of
motion
but if there's no net force on them
there must be some force that's
counteracting this force because if
there was nothing else there would be a
net force of gravity and this poor
toddler would be plummeting to the
center of the earth
so that net force in this situation is
the force of the floor of the elevator
supporting the toddler
so that force is an e this that force
is
would be the equal would be an equal
force but in the opposite direction and
in this case that would be the normal
force so in this case the normal force
is 98
98 newtons in
in the j direction so it just completely
bounces off there's no net force on this
person they get to hold their constant
velocity of zero and they don't plummet
to the center of the earth
now what is the net force on this
individual right over here well this
individual is accelerating there is
acceleration going on over here so there
must be some type of net force well
let's think about what the net force
must be on this person
or on this toddler i should say the net
force is going to be the mass of this
toddler is going to be 10 kilograms 10
kilograms times the acceleration of this
toddler
times 2
meters per second squared which is equal
to
20 kilogram meters per second squared
which is the same thing as 20 newtons 20
newtons upwards 20 newtons upwards is
the net force is the net force
so if we already have the force due to
gravity at at 98 newtons downwards
that's the same thing here that's that
one right over there 98 newtons
downwards we need a force that not only
balances off that 98 newtons downwards
to not only keep it stationary but it's
also doing another 20 newtons in the
upwards direction
so here we need a force in order for
this toddler to or the excel or this in
order for the the elevator to accelerate
the toddler upwards at 2 meters per
second you have a net force of positive
20 newtons or 20 newtons in the upward
direction or another way to think about
it
if you have if you have negative 98
newtons here you're going to need 20
more than that in the positive direction
so you're going to need 118 newtons
you're going to need 118 newtons
now in the j direction
so here where the elevator is
accelerating upward the normal force the
normal force is now 20 newtons higher
than it was there and that's what's
allowing this toddler to accelerate now
let's think about this situation
no acceleration but our velocity is but
our but we do have velocity so here we
were stationary here we do have velocity
and you might be tempted to think
oh there must be you know maybe i still
have some higher force here because i'm
moving upwards i have some upwards
velocity but remember newton's first law
of motion if you're at a constant
velocity including a constant velocity
of zero you have no net force on you
so this toddler right over here once the
toddler gets to this stage the net
forces are going to look identical over
here and actually if you're sitting in
either this elevator or this elevator
assuming it's not being bumped around at
all you would not be able to tell the
difference because you there's no your
your body is sensitive to acceleration
your body cannot sense its velocity if
it has no air or if it has no frame of
reference or nothing to see passing by
so the toddler there it doesn't know
whether it is stationary or whether it
has constant velocity it would be able
to tell this it would feel that that
kind of compression on its body and
that's what it's its nerves are
sensitive to or its perception is
sensitive to but here it's identical to
the first situation and newton's first
slot tells us there's no net force on
this so it's just like the first
situation the normal force the force of
the elevator on this toddler shoes is
going to be identical to the downward
force due to gravity so the normal force
here is going to be 98 newtons
completely nets out the downward the
negative 98 newtons so once again this
is in the j direction in the positive j
direction and then when we're about to
get our floor when we are about to get
to our floor
what is happening well once again we
have a net acceleration
we have a net acceleration of negative
two meters per second so if you have a
negative acceleration so once again what
is the net force here
the net force over here is going to be
the mass of the toddler
10 kilograms times negative 2 meters per
second negative
2 meters and this is in the this was
right here the j direction that's the
vertical direction remember j is just
the unit vector in the vertical
direction facing upwards so negative 2
meters per second squared
in the j direction and this is equal to
negative 20
kilogram meters per second squared in
the j direction or negative 20 newtons
in the j direction so the net force on
this is negative 20 newtons
so we have the force of gravity at
negative 98 newtons in the j direction
so we we're not
fully compensating for that because
we're still going to have a net negative
force while this this child is
decelerating and that negative net force
is a is a negative net force of oh i
keep repeating it negative 20. so we're
only going to have 78 we're only going
to have a 78 newton
normal force here that counteracts all
but 20 newtons of the force due to
gravity
so this right over here is going to be
78 newtons in the j direction
and so i really want you to think about
this and i actually really want you to
think about this next time you're
sitting in the elevator the only time
that you realize that something is going
on is when that elevator is really just
accelerating or when it's just
decelerating when it's just accelerating
you feel a little bit heavier and what's
just decelerating you feel a little bit
lighter and i want you to think a little
bit about why that is but while it's
moving at a constant velocity or
stationary you feel like you're just
sitting you know on the on the surface
of the planet someplace